-John, your character,
you're a police officer.
Your name is Gilbert Pewntz.
And that's not the only
great name in the show.
But Pewntz was the name
that you've long wanted
to find into a television show
-Yes. I -- I --
In the writers room at "SNL,
we try to just
write stupid names
to make the other writers laugh.
Not you, necessarily.
You --
It bothers you, doesn't it
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, I hate it.
-And then you would cut them
-[ Laughs ]
-But I originally
wrote this for David Spade
a character named Cane Pewntz...
-Cane.
-...who was teaching
the craft of kissing,
and his whole infomercial
was just about him
trying to get women
to come to his workshop
to practice kissing.
So the name --
Gilbert seemed a little more
friendly for this character,
but Pewntz has been somethin
that I've wanted to get --
put somewhere for a long time.
-You've worked with each other
You've written for each other,
maybe not as explicitly writte
for each other as you have now
but you know
each other's voices well.
Was there times
that you were writing line
that you would only ever
write for Paula,
and, Paula, were there lines
that John wrote
that delighted you
more than others?
-Yeah. Any --
Writing anything
with Gilbert's character
doing the funny --
'Cause John can just
do that sort of --
the sort of
low-self-esteem-based, like,
misunderstanding and then
sort of reiterating
and then trying to make sure
he's got the right instructions.
It was such a --
such a funny game with Gilbert
and such a homage to sort of
a Barney Fife type thing.
And so anytime I wrote anythin
that was coming out
of John's mouth,
I could hear it like he wa
sitting on my shoulder.
-[ Laughs ]
-And the same thing with Paula
Like, it's fun to make her
like, scream.
When she gets startled,
have her go, like,
"What in the squirrels?!"
[ Laughter ]
But her -- her voice just --
it's right there. Yeah.
-You also -- J.B. Smoove
is also in the show,
also a writer with us
back in the day,
and a person who is both
a joy to write for
and a joy to watch improvise
I would imagine.
-Oh, he's beyond funny.
He's a legend
in the pitch meetings at "SNL,
because it would get to him,
and he would just
very leisurely start pitching.
You know,
everyone is so nervous,
and they're kind of
meeting the host,
and they didn't have anythin
loaded up about
what's an idea
'cause it's Monday,
and they've only had, like
a day and a half
to think about it.
So they're like, you know,
freaking out.
And then it would get to him
and he'd just have the floor
you know?
He'd just be like,
"Yeah, something like --
like a 15-foot grill.
You know those grills?"
I was like,
"A 15-foot gas grill?"
And he would just keep going
and people would be dying.
I've also always said about J.B.
that he's the only person
I've ever seen audition
where Lorne put his head dow
on the table,
he was laughing so hard.
He had to like put --
at a comedy club,
and he had to, like,
put his head down
on the table and laugh.
And Hayley Magnus is my niece,
and she's like 6-feet tall
It's just a wonderful
group of eccentric characters.
We love it.
-And you guys have
taken advantage of the
Quibi platform with some -
There's some light nudity,
which is, uh...
you know, I am a great
appreciator of.
-Yeah. We're not gonna say
who's getting naked.
It's either me or John,
but let's just say
it's a nice set.
-[ Laughs ]
It's a nice,
heaving set that's revealed.
-It could also
be both of us, Paula.
[ Laughter ]
-It's both of us.
All I know is,
when we did the scene, we end up
both possibly being naked,
possibly nipples to the breeze
and we were crying
down into our bosoms, laughing
because we couldn't believ
we were doing this.
And we wrote it,
so we couldn't blame anyon
that we were just
out in the open air with..
-And this is a thing
now more than ever,
which is, I think,
a welcome change.
It's taken very seriously
when there's nudity on the set
-Oh, yeah.
-And yet you both
were incapable --
Because it was self-inflicted.
You wrote it for yourselves.
-Yeah.
-Incapable of taking it
seriously.
-No, we had that whole meeting
-Yep.
-Everybody -- we cleared the set
of any non-essential people.
I was very -- very serious
at first,
and then I take my shirt off
to cover Paula.
-[ Laughs ]
And then that's
when she starts laughing at me
because she's just looking
at my chest, laughing.
And then it was --
-Just 'cause the weight of it --
Can I compliment your chest?
Do I, okay, have permission?
-Sure.
-He just has a really
good chest, and he's got a nice,
you know, hair pattern.
But I -- I don't see it
that often, and so I --
I just realized, in a moment -
It was one of those
camera moments that just i
the focus pull, where all of
a sudden, I'm like,
"Oh, I'm standing out
in the cold with, like,
two crew members and a coyot
in the back lot of Universal
watching us
stand there naked."
-[ Laughs ]
But it's definitely worth --
it's definitely worth it
to ride that --
ride the "Mapleworth" trai
to get to that part.
-You do have an incredible
cast -- the two of you,
J.B., Hayley, and then a ton o
super-fun cameos of friend
that you guys have made over
your two decades in comedy
-Yeah.
-Yeah, we got super lucky
with everybody
who was able to do it.
It was awesome.
-Just a parade of
heavy-hitter --
heavy-hitter people.
-Yeah, we had --
-Tina and Andy Samberg and..
-Maya Rudolph.
-Maya Rudolph and Fred Armisen
-You know him so well.
He can't --
-Ike Barinholtz and Nicole Byer.
-You've never met
any of these people.
You barely can remember
their names.
-[ Laughs ]
-That one
that's in that one thing.
-[ Laughs ]
Um, I am --
-We don't have televisions
-Oh, you don't.
Oh, that's right.
You guys are readers.
I'm so excited for the show.
Paula, I should also mention
I'm so excited
that season three of "A.P. Bio
is about to start.
Those episodes are fantastic
That's coming
in September on Peacock.
And, John, I genuinely --
We were --
We were busting
each other's chops a littl
before this started.
I'm genuinely excited
to hopefully see you again soo
back at work.
-Ah, yes.
Me, as well.
-All right, I love you both.
-Love you!
Love you. Stay safe.
-Thank you. Stay safe.